[Zene]
üdvözlök mindenkit most beszéltem nemrég
dr kurtus arankával a hematológus
főorvossal itt székhelyudvarhelyen és
nagyon izgalmas témákat jártunk körbe
először is a hematológiát egy kicsit
körbe jáártuk hogy miről is szól és hogy
milyen esetekkel szembesül arankkal nap
min nap de ami személyesen engem nagyon
érdekelt az az hogy három gyerekes
családanyaként hogyan tudja egyeztetni a
szakmáját és a a magánéletét
és ami talán ennél is érdekesebb volt
számomra az az hogy ő személyesen azt a
nap mintnapi vagy hétről hétre
megismétlődő tragédiát hogy egy halálos
diagnózist kell adott esetben közöljön
ez hogyan éli meg hogyan tudja
integrálni a a az életével és és hogyan
küzd meg belül ezzel a ezzel az igazán
nehéz helyzettel hogy mindannyian
elmúlunk úgyhogy tartsatok velünk a
következő több mint egy órában egy
izgalmas beszélgetésben és iratkozzatok
fel a csatornánkra hogyha tetszett ez a
beszélgetés valamint hagyjatok egy
kommentet ugyanis a kommentek nagyon
segítenek abba egyrészt hogy
visszajelzéseket kapjak én is és hogy
egyre jobb legyen ez a műsor másrészt
pedig hogy minél több emberhez eljusson
ez a műsor szép napot nektek
sziasztok szervusz aranka köszöntelek a
műsorunkb nagyon örvendek hogy
elfogadtad a meghívásunkat mert be kell
hogy valljam hogy ez a téma az
egészségügy téma számomra egy elég vak
volt és ez egy jó lehetőség lesz
számomra is hogy egy kicsit úgy
belemenjek a a kérdéseknek a mélyébe
és például maga a hematológia mivel
foglalkozik é utána kellett nézzek
konkrétan ennek és amikor a cv-det is
elolvastam rájöttem hogy te jó ég mennyi
minden van itt amit alig tudok kiolvasni
tehát hogy tegnap a feleségemmel
kacagtunk vagyis ő pontosabban kacagott
rajtam hogy úgy olvassom ki mintogyha
egy két éves így a szótagokat így ahogy
olvassa ki ennek ellenére örvend hogy le
tudunk ülni és egy kicsit elmélyedni
ebben a témában mert rengeteg minden
érdekel ezzel kapcsolatban és az egyik
dolog ami megfogalmazódott bennem az az
hogy elolvasva a cvdet hogy mennyi
tanulás van mögötte tehát hogy röviden
például egy elemet kiemelek 2000-től
2006-ig végezted a az orvosi egyetemet
vásárhelyen ez hat év egyetem de még
utána gyakorlatilag ez a a cv-dnek ez az
első 10%-a a ami ami ami az egyetem
végzési vel kapcsolatos és utána a
szakképesítés ami 2014-ben történt
emesváron tényleg ennyi tanulást igényel
h igen tulajdonképpen igen köszönöm a
meghívást és köszönöm azt a csomó
információt amit úgy előtte megosztottál
velem merth hogy igazából ez keltette
fel bennem ez a beszélgetés iránt az
érdeklődést
gyakorlatilag ennek a
az emberi lelki vetületére való
ráérzésed hogy mennyire lenne ez fontos
esetleg megosztani másokkal is úgyhogy
köszönöm a lehetőséget hogy
beszélgethetünk a hematológiáról nem túl
gyakori pont azért mert hogy elég ritka
szakterület
még mindig tehát hogy úgy nagyjából
keresgéljük egymást szakemberek és
hogyha egy-egy kongresszus van akkor
szinte névsort lehet olvasni olvasni
hogy ki hiányzik tehát hogy nem szívesen
választották korábban ezt a
szakterületet a az orvoskollégák
egyrészt úgy gondolom hogy azért mert
hogy a betegségek jó része
kezelhetetlen volt egy diagnózis
pillanatáig úgy mindenki örült annak
hogy jaj dejuk tudjuk mi a baj de most
akkor már mi lesz
gondolom hogy fog ez változni mát óriási
fejlődésem ment át az elmúlt évek során
is nagyon sok mindenre megoldás
született és úgy gondolom hogy ezzel
hogy
a betegségek kimenetele is bizonyos
értelemben javult vagy gyógyíthatóvá
vált egyes
patológia gondolom hogy érdekesen v de
tudnál mondani olyan példát ami p az
elmúlt 20 évben oldódott meg igen
például egy krónikus meloid leukémia ami
még csak 20 évvel ezelőtt is elmondható
hogy halálos diagnózis volt mert nem
volt it rá kezelés gyakorlatilag most
már van olyan betegünk akit több mint 10
éve követünk és egy krón kikus beteg
szedegeti a gyógyszereit mint egy magas
vérnyomásos visszajár a rendelőbe a havi
vagy kéthavontai kontrolljára és éli a
gyakorlatilag minőségileg megszokott
életét és és még van jó néhány ilyen
példa hogy gyakorlatilag egy krónikus
idült betegséggé degradálódott az az
ijesztő hogy szó hogy leukémia egyes
fajtái egyes fajtái tényleg ijesztő szó
a leukémia és így hallgattam egy pár
interjút pont veled mondtad hogy vagy 20
alfaja is van lehet hogy annál több is a
leukémiának
tényleg ijesztő
így azok az esetek akik eljutnak hozzád
azokat hogy hogy képzeljem el mennyire
súlyosak vagy hogy akik eljutnak hozzád
azok már milyen stádiumban vannak
változó van úgy hogy egyszerűen csak egy
családorvos által vagy saját
meggondolásból elvégzett
rutinlaborvizsgálat
utal rá hogy itt valami baj van a a
vérképpel
máskor viszont sürgősségen keresztül az
utolsó stádiumban tehát hogy ez nagyon
széles a spektrum hogy ki hogyan kerül
hozzánk az a jó hogyha véletlenszerűen
időben kerül felfedezésre már azt
jelenti hogy a beteg még tünetmentes
igazából és hogy nagyon sok
alternatívánk van akkor még megtervezni
a kezelést vagy a kivizsgálást tehát
gondolom hogy itt is érvényes az hogy
minél hamarabb jut el hozzád valaki igen
annál annál nagyobb az esélye annál több
eszközöd van a kezedben anná így van így
van amikor készültem erre a podcastre én
általában úgy készülök a podcastteekre
hogy hatalmas listányi kérdést írok és
utána aztán kiszűröm azokat amelyek
duplikáltak és amelyek nem annyira
érdekesek és pár napi készülés után
nyilván nem reggeltől estig készülök
hanem pár napi így forgatom a kérdést
így magamban hogy lassan kialakul egy
egy ilyen témakör hogy mi az ami
számomra fontos és az első kérdés ami
megfogal azódott bennem így a a a már a
legelején az az hogy valahogy úgy látok
egy analógiát így úgy ahogy például az
alkímiának a a tehát az alkímia volt a
kémiának az alapja és nyilván hogy a
mostani modern kémia és az alkémia
között alig van hasonlóság és sőt egy
egy ilyen egy ilyen furcsa misztikus
szimbolikus köd veszi körbe az alkémiát
míg a kémia az egy tudomány hasonlóan
érzem én is azt hogy mint hogyha
valahogy a hematológia és a az érvágás
között lenne valami valami misztikus
kapcsolat mert ugye a az egyik elterjedt
gyógymód az az érvágás volt arra
gondoltak hogy az egyik problémája a a
betegségeknek az egyik okozója az a
rossz vér amit hogyha kiengedünk akkor a
megfelelő módon akkor akkor
meggyógyulnak a páciensek királyok
kezeltették így magukat és nem tudom
hogy mekkora sikerrel gyanítom hogy
kevés sikerrel de te úgy látsz-e
valamennyi hasonlóságot így a
hematológia és az érvágásö hát
megmosolyogtat hogy erre az egész ősi
módszerre vezethető vissza a hematológia
nem is gondoltam eddig rá ameddig te így
rá nem kérdezel hogy hogy hihetetlen
hogy még ma is használom ezt a módszert
néha
néha de tényleg érdekes az hogy talán
már az egyiptomiak tehát több 1zer éves
ez a ez a módszer hogy érvágás egészen
misztikus módon használták ezt tény és
tényleg nem sok sikerrel tehát nagyon
sokszor például egy lábamputációt
végezve nagyjából az általuk gondolt
vérmennyiséget kiengedték a betegből
hogy kevesebbet vérezzen tehát nyilván
hogy hogy ez csak fokozta súlyosbította
a problémát de egész magas
í politikusokat is kezeltek
tüdőgyulladást példá igen érvágással és
sajnos rossz kimináell igen
jelen pillanatban azért egyetlen egy
alkalommal használjuk azt hogy lebocsát
uk tudatosan kezelés céljából a beteg
vérét akkor hogyha nagyon besűrűsödik
egy úgynevezett policitémia vérra nevű
betegségben illetve ritkább esetben a a
hemokromatózis nevű betegségben amikor
felhalmozódik a vas a szervezetbe vagyis
vasanyagcsere probléma van és akkor
ezzel próbáljuk üríteni a vasmennyiséget
de valójában ezzel hígul a vér nem hogy
ha folyadékot viszünk be és a vérünkből
kiengedünk akkor igen igen így van így
van hát veszteség van igen gyakorlatilag
ez a két eset amiben még néha
alkalmazzuk ezt az ősi módszert ezután
azt hiszem ahányszor vércsapolást fogok
végezni mindig az fog eszembe jutni hogy
érvágás és egyiptomiak igen de
véletlenül így tudsz arról hogy ez mikor
maradt abba mikor jött rá az
orvostudomány arra hogy ez ez ez egy
dvút hát gyakorlatilag úgy az 1600-as
években sebész írta le először azt hogy
a a vér az egy zárt rendszerben kering
tehát hogy a az erekbe és nem csak úgy
valahol van a testben hát hogy ott
valahol el vanan minden között a vér
tehát hogy nem nem eg ez az 1600-as
években került leírásra először hogy
tehát úgy ahogy a szivacs felszívja a
vizet úgy gyakorlatilag mindenhol ott a
vér mert azt látták hogy az izomban is
ott van a vér és így van de hogy ez egy
zársrendszer akkor ez egy ez egy új
dolog volt 16y új az 1600-as években
aztán néhány évtizedre rá egy
kezdetleges mikroszkóppal felfedezték a
az első vörös vérsejtet vagy leírták egy
angol orvos azt követően aztán ezt is az
1600-as évek igen igen aztán az 1800-as
években került sor az első
vérátömlesztésre emberről emberre addig
próbálkozások voltak mindenfélével
tehát lassú a folyamat nyilván hogy
lassú és ijesztő is belegondolni hogy
hogy rájövünk hogy mekkorá tévedtünk
tehát tát hogy az elmúlt 200 év vagy az
elmúlt 400 év egy-egy stratégiája
mennyire téves volt hogy bennem úgy
visszanézve ezt a a történetet az az a
kérdés merült fel hogy az amit most mi
annyira szentnek és biztosnak tudunk
néhány száz év múlva vajon a következő
generáció hogyan fog ránézni
hogy tényleg jó a megközelítésünk amit
tegyük fel az egyetemen szentnek és
igaznak vélt véltél és most kiderült az
elmúlt 20-30 évben hogy ez ez megfordult
igen tehát hogy például voltak konkrétan
a a krónikus limfás leukémiás
betegeinket attól a pillanattól kezdve
ahogy kiderült a diagnózis máris
kemoterápiára tettük és elkezdtük
kezelni az elmúlt néhány évben teljesen
megváltozott ennek a stratégiája
megfigyelés alatt tartjuk addig ameddig
megfelelő stádiumba el nem ér ameddig a
klinikuma nem romlik annyira hogy
szükségeltessenek kezelés és nagyon
kevés százaléka az aki
kemoterápiát kap tehát teljesen más
megközelítések vannak monoklonális
antitestekkel vagy receptorgátró
gyógyszerekkel kezeljük őket tehát
hogyha csak ezt az egy diagnózist nézem
a sok más mellett akkor azt mondom hogy
csak az én szemem láttára változott meg
teljesen a a a módszere egy-egy betegség
leírásának vagy kezelésének nyilván
hozzájárul az hozzá hogy
a technika a az információáramlás az egy
kicsit megváltozott és akkor ezzel
sokkal gyorsabban lehet hatékonyabban új
módszerekhez ket
kifejleszteni meg tanulni tehát hogy nem
úgy történik a tanulás hogy beülünk a
könyvtárba és keresgélünk évszázados
módszerek között hanem hanem ime itt van
a chat
gbt tényleg használod a chat gpt-t arra
hogy t nem nem még még nem jutott eddig
eszembe de most úgy nagyon é érdekes
volt ennek margójára ezután úgy
belekukkantani hogy mit tudna
nyújtani úgy gondolom hogy viszont
tényleg használható lenne
információ szűrésére a megfelelő
módszerre de nyilván hogy azt az
információt fogja szűrni amit tudüüm azt
az információt nem fogja szűrni amit nem
tud és a betegkapcsolatban a beteg az
egy egyedi információ vele szóba kell
állni és úgy gondolom hogy ez évszázadok
évezredek múlva is nem fog változni hogy
hogy az ember egyedi és nagyon egyedien
tud reagálni egy-egy betegségre egy egy
kezelésre és hogy nagyon sokat számít az
interperszonális kapcsolat orvosbeteg
kapcsolat tehát hogy úgy gondolom hogy
ezt nem tudjuk kizárni bármennyire is
fejlődjön ez a technika és a média és
igen látunk dolgokat közösségi médiában
beszélhetünk
úgymond v whatsappon és chatten
mindenféleképpen egymásral de érezzük
azt hogy nem ugyanaz a mint amikor ott
van mellettem
és szemembe néz és érzem a szagát vagy
az illatát vagy a szóval egészen más a
hangulat van ennek örvendek hogy ezt
mondod mert ez a másik téma ami nagyon
sokat foglalkoztat ez a a mesterséges
intelligencia hogy mely területek
lesznek amiket át kell adjunk mert
bölcsebb átadni és melyek amiket így se
úgy se fog tudni átvenni és amit én
megtapasztaltam eddig a chat gpt-vel az
az hogy olyan minthogyha lenne egy egy
nagyon-nagyon művelt asszisztens
mellettem akinek a lexikális tudása
kimeríthetetlen de másik oldalról pedig
ha nem vezetem akkor összezevissza
csapong maga a a a folyamata a chat
gpt-nek ahogy próbál felépíteni egy
gondolati
egy gondolatmenetet úgyhogy például el
tudom képzelni hogy egy diagnózis
felállítása előtt le ellenőrizni egy
chat gpt-vel hogy tényleg az a tudás
amit én úgy emlékezni vélek
rá még még érvényese de valójában az
hogy egy egy beteg önmát diagnosztizálja
chat gpt-vel én valahogy olyan furcsának
tűnik nekem vagy nem tudom hogy el tudom
képzelni például hogy hogy a chat gpt
azt mondja hogy ezek nagyon-nagyon
valószínű hogy hogy egy hematológushoz
kell menj ezzel a problémával de én nem
fogom tudni neked ezt megoldani és akkor
egy hematológus lesz az amelyik helyben
ember ileg el tudja dönteni hogy melyik
a helyes út tehát a morális döntéseket
nem hiszem hogy egy egy mesterséges
intelligencia el fogja tudni az etikai
kérdéseket nilván hogy nem de de még
ennél kevesebbet is tehát úgy gondolom
hogy ha csak belegondolok hogy esetleg a
chat gbt előhozna nekem információkat
egy teljesen más szakterületből legyen
az jogi vagy architekturális vagy olyan
kér építészet amihez én egyáltalán nem
értek
akkor akkor olyan szavakat
összefüggéseket fog nekem információként
közölni amivel én nem tudok mit kezdeni
tehát ha a saját szakterületemen belül
keresek ezzel információkat akkor nekem
segítség tehát hogyha az utolsó
kutatási módszerek vagy lehetőségek
kezelések fel vannak töltve és ez általa
így kiszűrhető akkor akkor én azokat
tudom használni de ha nem értek hozzá ha
nem ismerem az összefüggéseket akkor
nekem hasznaavehetetlen tehát nyilván
hogy attól mondjuk rákérdezhetsz hogy ha
nem érted akkor rákérdezhetsz hogy itt
mire gondoltál és egyre mélyebbre és
mélyebbre de azt hiszem hogy amire
mennyire kell nekem építésznek lenni
orvosként hogyha egy házat akarok
építeni nem szeretném megtanulni tehát
hogy igen ezért majd lesznek építészek
igen tehát hogy nyilván úgy gondolom
hogy ezeket az információkat a meg a
helyén kell kezelni én amit még érzek
nem tudom hogy mennyire tudod ezt
alkalmazni a pályafutásodra is hogy a
chat gpt örökké a arról fog beszélni
hogy tehát a miről hogy mit tapasztalt
tényeknek a halmazáról összefüggésekről
és nem a miértről a miértről sosem fog
tudni egy mesterséges intelligencia
beszélni tehát mindig úgy közelíté meg
minthogyha egy logikai kérdés lenne
aiértet is de a a az igazán fontos
kérdések hogy például egy diagnózisnál
miért várjunk azért mert az aktuális
kontextust érzed érzékeled gondolom a
családot a a az a a betegnek a státusát
hogy pszicholó pszichésen hogy áll éppen
fel van-e készülve ezeket nem fogja
tudni eldönteni egy mesterséges
intelligencia így van kicsit vissza
akarok még ugrani így a az
önéletrajzodhoz
mert kirajzolódott számomra egy nagyon
érdekes kép így rólad és kíváncsi vagyok
hogy hogy ez tényleg így van-e tehát
hogy a a hallgatók
kedvéért mondanám el hogy az első
egytizede az önéletrajznak körülbelül az
egyetem ami hat éves és utána
két szakképesítés ez 2014 és 21-ben
tehát hogy a hét évre rá nem 14 évre rá
nem nyolc évre rá hogy hogy elvégezted
az egyetemet igen 2016 bocsánat 2006-tól
2014-ig és utána 2021-ben egy következő
szakképesítés de időközben gyerekek is
születtek ugye ha jól értem három
gyermekes családanyaja vagy hogy tudtad
ezeket a ja igen és akkor persze ez a
másik 20%-a az önéletrajznak és a többi
az a a hatalmas lista publikáció amit
időközben néha az az érzésem hogy a
gyerekvállalás az a pihenés része
volt tehát hogy a az első gyerekünk az
egyetem idő alatt született én hatod
évet úgy kezdtem hogy egy négy hetes
baba volt az ölembbe gyakorlatilag és
így így államvizsgáztam aztán egy évet
otthon
maradtam gyerekkel a köv közbeszúrok egy
kérdést ezt hogy élted meg hogy a
szakmai szempontból hogy hogy hogy hogy
most tegyük fel kihívásként
fel se merült az hogy hogy én emiatt fel
kellene adnom a hivatásomat tehát hogy
valószínű hogy ez azért is így
belegondolva most hirtelen hogy mertogy
a család támogatott ebbe tehát hogy a
férjem úgy állt mellém hogy ez az élet
része nyilván gyereket akarunk vállalni
az hogy most vállalunk később vállalunk
mindig valamilyen áldozattal fog ez
járni bizonyos értelemben áldozattal
most így utólag visszagondolva újra azt
állítom hogy a pihenés része volt az
életemnek mert hogy mertogy ez azt
jelentette hogy arra az időszakra otthon
voltam és és csak velük
voltam szinte csak tehát hogy mindig
bele került azért valamilyen pluszképzés
hol ez hol az valamilyen továbbképzük
még ezt ezekbe az időszakokbaan is de de
többnyire a család mellett voltam és ez
és ez pozitív hozadéka tehát hogy nem
nem gondolom hogy külön kellene ezt
választani hogy családi élet karrier
mertogy ez az élet az én életem úgy az
egész teljességében és akkor ezt
valahogy úgy kell alakítani
dinamizmusába hogy mindenkinek jó legyen
a családbaan
és van amikor én szorulok több
támogatásra van amikor a család másik
tagja és ez így van rendjén ez így van
rendj ami tetszik ebb amit mondtál hogy
én magamban azt fogalmaztam meg pár
évvel ezelőtt hogy tudod egy ilyen belső
viaskodásom volt hogy hogy szakemberként
programozóként cégvezetőként mennyit
szabad elvegyek a családtól és amikor a
gyermekeimmel lehetek és miért nem
játszok örökké velük és miért nem vagyok
örökké velük és ez egy ilyen folyamatos
lelkiismeretfordulás vogy az idealizált
szülő kép a fejemben nem szűnik meg a
frusztráció bennem sem ha ez a két tehát
hog mindig volt egy ilyen hátsó hogy
sehol nem vagyok elég j hogy sehol nem
vagy elég na de én ezt azzal oldottam
fel magamban kíváncsi vagyok a
véleményedre hogy valójában a
gyermekeimnek kell mutassak egy olyan
képet hogy felnőttnek lenni jó hogy
felnőttnek lenni izgalmas és akarjanak
ők is felnőni tehát ne akarjanak örökké
gyerekek maradni mert hogyha azt a képet
mondom nekik hogy most ez a legszebb
korszaka az életednek ameddig gyermek
vagy játszodj ameddig tudsz és és nem is
zavarlak meg sőt én is mindent
feláldozok azért hogy a gyermekemmel
tudjak lenni ennek van egy olyan torsz
hozadéka s szerintem hogy a gyermek
örökké gyermek akar majd maradni mert
azt látja hogy felnőttlek lenni nem jó
és ha azt látja hogy egy identitást ad
az hogy felnőtt vagy a szakmád egy
identitást ad fontos dolgokkal tudsz
foglalkozni birkózni olyan feladatokkal
amelyek lehetetlennek tűnnek és e ez az
az a kalandnak a definíciója és hogyha
egy gyermek majd később kalandot keres
akkor rájön arra hogy felelősséget akar
majd vállalni és hasonló akarok lenni
mint anya hasonló akarok lenni mint apa
amit azt jelenti hogy néha áldozatot
kell hozzak néha kényelmetlen helyzetbe
kell hozzam magam és ezt ilyen
szempontból fontos hogy például amikor
én erre gondoltam hogy hogy most nem a
lányommal vagyok de a lányom tudja hogy
dolgozom vagy pedig behívom az irodába
mellém vagy üljön le hogy a számítógép
mellé amikor programozok hogy nézze hogy
mit csinálok hogy tanuljon ebből is
valahogy érzel-e valami hasonlóságot
ebbe
hogy érd
nem nem feltétlen gondoltam azt hogy
hogy be kellene vonnom a szakmai
területbe lehet hogy lehet hogy
tudatosan vagy tudatalattiban is valahol
óvni akartam őket ezek ennek a terhétől
gyerekeimet úgy igazából nem nem
gondoltam arra hogy feltétlen
hematológus kellene legyen bármelyikük
tehát hogy meg úgy gondolom hogy meg
kell találja mindegyik a a saját útját
és ez azzal hogy esnek példát tőlünk
remélem hogy pozitívat is az jó de nem
nem gondolom hogy ezt én fogom
megharcolni helyettük csak ott tudok
lenni esetleg ha szükség van rám a
támogatásomra
nagyon érdekes család vagytok amúgy a
hallgató kedvéér akik értül nem
ismernétek a kurtus családot
a kurtus istván ő ortopéd főorvos és
aranka te hematológus főorvos vagy
úgyhogy két orvos egy családban és mind
a ketten tudom hogy hatalmas terhet tek
a vállatokon meg gyakorlatilag a cv-n
ezért rugózok ennyit mert a cv az egy
tükörképe egy egyszerűsített példája
annak hogy mennyi munka van mögötte
tehát hogy ezeket a cikkeket megírni
gondolom hogy a szívedet lelkedet
beleraktad ezekbe a cikkekbe is tehát
hogy azért odafigyeltél hogy ami kimegy
a kezed közül az olyan minőségű legyen
ami amihez a nevedet szívesen adod és
ezeknek a dátumai az pont a
gyermeknevelések között mert három
gyermek három gyerekes családban vagytok
és igen a második gyerekünk az a
rezidens képzés alatt született és a
harmadik gyerekünk pedig már szakorvos
kintitt udvarhelyen és ha jól
visszagondolok azt hiszem hogy a
harmadiknál volt a legnehezebb
megharcolni azt hogy h gyerekvállalás
mert már akkor
egy jó nagy betegszám állt mögöttem aki
arra várt hogy hogy kezelést fog kapni
és ráadásul pont abban a szituációban
amikor két megyében egyedül voltam
hematológus és akkor a a ennek a a
harmadik terhességnek az utolsó hónapja
arról szólt hogy mindegyik betegnek
valahol orvost keríteni hogy a következő
hónapban ki fogja ellátni tehát hogy
ilyen értelemben azt hiszem ez volt a a
legmegterhelőbb gyerekvállalás tehát
volt olyan hogy sírva ment a beteg a
rendelőből el hogy akkor most mi lesz
vele és igen az akkor úgy lelkileg úgy
érzem hogy megterhelő volt
másrészt viszont úgy gondolom hogy hogy
igen dolgozunk de mindenki dolgozik
tehát hogy a mi feladatunk ez a mi
feladatkörünk de más család is reggel
6:00tól esetleg este
810-ig elvégzi a feladatát azt ami az ő
feladata vagy nem egy család kénytelen
egyik vagy másik szülőt hiányolni a
munka miatt mertogy olyan a feladatköre
hogy elutazik vagy vagy hosszú időn
ideig nincs családapa vagy családanya a
munkája miatt tehát hogy nem feltét
gondolom hogy nekem nehezebb lenne mint
másnak tehát
ezt ti hogy oldottátok meg praktikusan
hogy oldottáok meg a két praxis mellett
meg magánrendelés is istván mindenképpen
tudom hogy magánrendelést is tartott
vagy tart folyamatosan és azt hiszem
most már te is
igen egy hetente egy alkalommal csak a
változatosság kedvéér al szóval hy ezt
hogy tudtátok logisztikailag hogy hogyan
képzeljem el hát érdekes volt az életünk
alakulása pont emi miatt mertogy óriási
a gyerek korosztály különbség tehát
minden generációból van úgyhogy a
nagyobbik lányunk gyakorlatilag mire én
úgy kezdtem jobban belelendülni a
munkába ő már ovis volt tehát volt egy
napközis program amihez lehetett
alkalmazkodni vagy volt egy sülis
program amihez lehetett
alkalmazkodni a következő gyerek
születésénél nagyon sok mindenben már ő
is tudott támogatni vagy segíteni vagy
besegíteni a családba egy egy órára vagy
két órára gyerekfelügyelet nem nem lett
kérdés hogy kilépek vásárolni akkor most
létszi figyelj a
kisebbre aztán amikor intenzívebb lett a
munka akkor segítséget kértünk édesanyám
szokott jönni iskolaidőben hozzánk
segíteni és ez nekünk nagyon jó mekkora
ádás a szigű így van
és és ez biztonságot jelentett ugye a
gyerekeknek hogyha hazajönnek akkor van
ki kinyissa az ajtót és nem egy kulcslóg
nyakába tehát hogy ilyen értelemben ez
nagy segítség volt meg támaz meg most is
az mikor jön ha tetszik ez az epizód
akkor kérlek iratkozz fel a csatornánkra
vagy írd meg kommentbe hogy milyen más
témáról hallanálég szívesen
így a másik témakör ami foglalkozhat
mostanában az anyaság kérdése ez nyilván
amiatt mert nekem is három gyermekem van
és és a feleségemmel rengetegszer
szembesülünk azzal a kérdéssel hogy hogy
azért megvan te terhelve manapság az
anyaság a mármint az aki szeretne a
szakmai életben is előrehaladni az a is
most már több anyával is beszélgettem
folyamatosan az az érzésük hogy ha
gyermeket fognak vállalni akkor ennek az
lesz a következménye hogy ott kell
hagyják a praxisukat vagy eleve
hátrányból fognak indulni mire megint
odakerülnek hogy hogy bele tudják vetni
magukat
és itt érzek egy olyan hazugságot hogy
ez már nem csak hazugság tehát nem tudom
hogy hogy talán úgy lehet megfogalmazni
hogy van a vannak a füllentések vannak a
torzítások akkor vannak a nagyobb
hazugságok és ha egyre nagyobb
hazugságokat akkor a végén már ott van
egy olyan antiigazság ami már nem lehet
másképp meg az igazságnak a pont az
ellenkezője és én érzek valami ilyesmit
ebben hogy ez ami ez az érzet amit úgy
megfogalmazunk de nem tudjuk azért
annyira kimondani hogy hogy hátrányban
vannak-e a nők miután szülnek én
rájöttem arra hogy itt már több példát
is láttam arra hogy ez egy ez egy
antiigazság
vagyis hogy elmondom konkrétan a
feleségem építész és rá kellett jöjjek
arra hogy azáltal hogy azt a hét évet
otthon
végigülte azáltal nemcsak hogy nem
maradt le a szakmájába hanem jobb
építésszé vált mert ki tud egy családi
házat megtervezni az a a személy akinek
családja nem volt soha vagy az aki végig
élte az minden logisztikai apró kicsi
kérdést megkellett tanuljon és a
gyermekeknek a az igényeit ki hogyan
működik egy család ezt egy családanyaja
tudja a legjobb jobban a belső dinamikát
és nemrég egy pár hónappal ezelőtt
beszélgettem egy szín és
stílustanácsadással foglalkozó hölggyel
aki ezen gondolkozott hogy hogy
vállaljon-e gyermeket vagy ne vállaljon
és pont ez fogalmazódott meg bennem hogy
hát vajon ki tudja a stílus tanácsadásba
a hogy hogy egy egy nőnek akinek
változik a teste mire van szüksége
hogyan tud felöltözni úgy hogy méltó
legyen és ízléses hát nyilván hogy egy
családanya jobban tudja vajon a te eset
ben ez érvényes-e hogy jobb szakemberré
váltál-e azáltal hogy hogy gyermekeket
vállaltál és és és emberekkel
foglalkoztál így belülről nem tudom hogy
jobb szakemberré váltam-e de annyi
biztos hogy nem volt a hátrányomra tehát
nem foghatom a családomra sőt nem
foghatom a gyereknevelésre az hogyha én
szakmailag
lemaradtam remélem hogy nagyon nem
maradtam le de tehát hogy úgy gondolom
hogy hogy ott van a
lehetőség annyi szakkönyvet
és cikket elolvasni mint gyereknevelés
alatt soha nem fogok a hétköznapjaimban
mertogy egyszerűen nem jut rá idő mert
ott van a beteg anyag akit el kell látni
a a hétköznapi feladatok a munka és
akkor viszont otthon voltam a gyerekkel
is volt erre idő tehát hogy bizonyos
értelemben egyik fajta tanulásnak a
lehetősége sokkal inkább
kihangsúlyozódott arra az időszakra az
tény hogy én nem használtam ki a
maximális lehetőséget a gyereknevelésre
ezért gördültek így az évek tehát hogy
egy-egy évet voltam otthon mind három
gyerekkel
és utána visszamentem dolgozni ennek nem
feltétlen az volt az oka hogy hogy nem
akartam otthon lemaradni a a szakmáról
hanem egyszerűen egymáshoz viszonyítva a
férjemmel a képzésünk ne tolódjon el
annyira hogy hosszabb távon kelljen
esetleg majd
egymástól távol munkát keressün tehát a
rezidens képzésnél ő amúgy is előrébb
volt
két évvel én még egy-egy évet lemaradtam
a gyereknevelés miatt é hogy ne ne
kelljen ezt a család így megszenvedje
tehát ezért igyekeztem tartani a lépést
az évekkel is meg azért minden szakmának
nem csak ott a van a szakmai
intellektuális oldala de ott van egy
csomó olyan tulajdonsága minden egyes
szakmának ami ami logisztikát igényel
belső fegyelmet igényel emberi
kapcsolatot diplomáciát igényel ezekben
határozottan fejlődiká ez a lényege a
családnak ez a lényege egy családnak
igen tát amikor nem én akkor ő és igen
vannak bakik amiket ki kell j és ezeket
gondolom nap mint nap használod amikor
konfliktust kell kezelni vagy egy
nyilvánán nilván úgyhogy kedves anyák
ezt tudom mondani nektek hogy
vállaljatok gyermeket mert nem maradtok
le semmiről sőt életet hoztok a világban
és és számomra ez egy fontos hogy
bátorítsá folyamatosan a a a
családanyákat mert mert nem pont az
ellenkezője fog történni amúgy
megkérdezted volna ugyane ezt hogy hogy
ha nem nőként ülök itt hanem esetleg egy
orvosként hogy hogy boldogulsz három
gyerekkel családapaként igen igen tehát
a a ha istvánnal ültem volna le biztos
megkérdeztem volna mert hogy általában
azért úgy a sztereotípiák kialakulnak
hogy ez csak a nő
nehézsége feladata há az az igazság hog
nekem is van három gyermekem és látom
hogy ez nem működik ez nem egy egy egy
szereplős tánc amit han folyamatosan én
is otthon részt kell vegyek és
és és részt is veszek úgyhogy ilyen
szempontból nekem egyértelmű hogy te nem
önmagadban létezel itt hanem és istván
sem önmagában létezik hanem valójában ez
egy dinamika valójában azt vettem észre
a mi családunknál hogy amikor ketten
éltünk a feleségemmel
csak meg kellett halalljunk és újjá
kellett szülessünk akkor amikor
megszületett az első lányunk egy
háromgyerekes családként kellett
újjászülessünk és az hogy meghaltunk az
azt jelenti hogy olyan dolgokat amiket
addig csináltunk és értékesnek
tartottunk el kellett engedjünk és
amikor megszületett a második lányom
akkor ugyanúgy ez történt hogy
meghaltunk és közösen újjá születtünk ha
csak a feleségem hal meg és születik
újjá akkor egyre jobban eltávolodunk és
én is meg kellett haljak és a meghalás
az nem egy kellemes dolog és most már
harmadszor megtörtént ez és már újra egy
családi
egységet létre tudtunk hozni és hogyha
még vállalnánk gyermeket vagy akár örök
befogadáson is gondolkozunk akkor
ugyanúgy meg kell majd halljunk még
egyszer ez egy közös tánc hogy ha ha én
nem teszem meg azt akkor egyszerűen
lemaradok erről a csodáról amit egy
család jelent úgyhogy visszatérve a
kérdésedre én én érteni vélem hogy ez a
komplex logisztika ami a háttérben van
ez ugyanúgy nyomja istvánt is ha ő részt
akar venni ebbe de én tudom hogy hogy
azért az azért ez egy közös tánc a ti
életetekben igen igen meg újra mondom
tehát hogy adva volt a szituáció hogy a
gyerekek különböző generációban vannak
és a család részeként ők is odatették a
saját feladatuk elvégzésével azt hogy
jól működjön a dolog tehát hogy
segítettek
egyértelműen kicsit visszamennék a
szakmádhoz
is ami számomra egy kérdés az az
hogy kezdjük egy egyszerűb kérdéssel
milyen típusú betegek szoktak megkeresni
téged milyen milyen általánosabb gyakori
betegségek vannak amit akár itt a kicsi
udvarhelyi kórházban is tudunk kezelni
tehát a a hemat olológia az a
vérvérképzőrendszer megbetegedéseivel
foglalkozik és
gyakorlatilag nagyon sokszor szembesülök
azzal a a kérdéssel hogy akkor amikor
csontvelőt veszek a betegtől mertogy ott
történik a vérképzés akkor nagyon sokan
megijednek hogy nem szeretném hogy a
gerincemhez nyúljanak vagy a
gerincvelőmhöz semmi köze kettőnek
egymáshoz úgyhogy
igen a vérképzőrendszerrel foglalkozik
és ezeknek a megbetegedéseivel
ö széles a spektrum mivel egy
határterület
a belgyógyászat az onkológia és a
transzfúziológia közötti határterület
ezért nagyon sok mindennel
foglalkozik azt hiszem az egyetlen olyan
különálló szakterület ami a
rosszindulatú megbetegedéseket is
ellátja ugyanis a többi szakterületeknél
ha kiderül hogy valahol egy daganatos
megbetegedés van az átkerül az
onkológiára nálunk nem tehát hogy a
hematológiai megbetegedések rossz
indulatú részét is a hematológia látja
el és akkor itt azért ilyen széles a
spektrum mer az egyszerű vashiányos
vérszegénységtől az akut leukémiákig
minden benne van
de benne van a nyirokdaganat a multiplex
mielóma ami a csontvelőnek egy speciális
plazmasejtes rosszindulatú megbetegedése
és mindenféle fajta vérzés vagy
vérzékenys vérzékenységet
okozó problémák koagulációs zavarok na
szóval minden van benne és akkor ha jól
értettem vannak fekvőbetegek és vannak
járóbetegek járóbetek
a hány ágy van most jelenleg a kórházban
aki hozzátartozik 10 ágyas részleggel
működik integrált részeként a
bágyógyászati osztálynak azen kívül
napos befektetéseket is végzünk ez egy
teljesen különálló területen és van van
a járóbeteg rendelő ami mindennapos
működés h hogy érzed túl vagy-e terhelve
igen
határozötan tehát hogy még még szükség
lenne egy hematológus orvosra nyilván
tehát az lenne a jó hogyha ha nem lenne
az kérdés hog én elmegyek 10 napra
szabadságra akkor az a 10 nap alatt mi
történik a betegekkel tehát hogyha ezt
nem kellene előre megtervezni hogy ki
mikor betegedjen meg és mikor kapja meg
a kezelését hanem hogy ez legyen magától
értetődő hogy legalább felváltva tudjuk
a onág b akor most mi történik hogyha el
mész szabadságra akkor csikszeredai
kollégával igyekszem egyeztetni hogy ha
ő van akkor az olyan sürgősségi eseteket
azt átveszi vagy egyetemi központokba
kerülnek a betegek vagy a kolozsvári
vagy a
marosvásárhelyi akkor gondolom a
szabadnapjai mindig meg vannak terhelve
igen általában az első napok
telefonálással telnek hogy aki még nem
találta meg a helyét vagy van egy új
eset akkor hovas mi az útja a
betegnek nem egyszerű az egyet központok
is túlterheltek tehát hogy még csak
elküldeni se könnyű a beteget mert hogy
nagyon sokszor azzal szembesülünk hogy
nincs kiifogadja és akkor adva van a
helyzet hogy mindent el kell látni
igyekszünk tényleg nem elküldeni a
betegeket azon eseteket szoktam
elküldeni akik
valamilyen terápiás stratégia folytán
olyan kezelést igényelnek ami izolálást
igényel külön kortermet vagy vagy trans
plantációár ős sejtátüttetésre szorul
mertogy az az a jó hogyha az illető
centrumba kezdi el a kezelését ezt nem
tudjuk megcsinálni gondolom nem és a az
országban is három most már talán négy
helyen működik a gondolom vásárhely
kolozsvár kolozsvár most kezdi csak
tehát eddig kolozsváron se volt
vásárhely és bukarest volt illetve
temesvár a transzplantációs központ
temesvár többnyire gyerekekre
szakosodott úgyhogy gyakorlatilag az
országban maradt kettő a vásárhely és a
bukaresti és szinte ességtelen volt hogy
minden beteg időbe bekerüljön merthogy
nem volt hely ez úgy adva adva van a
helyzet ez hogy nem tud időbe bekerülni
ez nem tud időbe
bekerülni a amire bekerülni a rendszerbe
addig már meg addig már késő addig már
késő mennyire gyakori hogy halállal
találkozol addig már késő hát nem
mondanám hogy gyakoribb feltétlen mint
egy átlagos belgyógyászati osztályon még
akkor is hogyha rossz indulatú betegség
foglalkozom
mertogy nem nagyobb a halálozási rátája
de hogy az én szakmában az én szakmámban
a halálozási ráta nagyonnagyon alacsony
úgyhog hogy kéz alacsony tehát egyik
szakmában se alacsony mert hogyha
belegondolsz akkor az élet része az hogy
meghalunk tehát hogy megszülettünk és
valahol ott benne van előbb-utóbb az
öreged is következtében is hogy hogy
meghalunk igen de aki aki már közelebb
kerül akkor orvoshoz k ül nem nem
programozóhoz úgyhogy úgyhogy ilyen
szempontból távoli és nek emlékszem
amikor az unokaestvéremmel történt ez
meg ő 25 éves volt és
egy egy egy trombózisa volt
valójában nagyon
hamar nagyon hamar történt minden engem
tragikusan ért engem lesújtott és és
akkor tehát akkor én is 26 éves voltam
vagy 27 talán és és emlékszem akkor
miért először ennyire közelről mer
valahogy úgy voltam vele hogy a halál az
megtörténik mással mással de velem nem
vagy az én környezetembbenán és minél
fiatalabban következik be akkor annál
inkább érint minket érzelmileg és ez és
ez a rendjén van mert hogy az előbb mint
mondtam a gyakorlatilag az öregség lenne
a normális halálok amit úy el tudnánk
fogadni észszerűen és nem egy fiatalk
korba történt betegség vagy tragédia
baleset nem könnyű feldolgozni nem
könnyű feldolgozni a diagnóziss se de
nem tudom feltétlen korhoz se kötni ezt
hogy amikor van egy egy rossz indulatú
diagnózis amivel szembesül a paciens
hogy az esetleg függne attól hogy fiatal
vagy öreg vagyok van úgy hogy 80
pluszosan igen azt mondja a beteg hogy
hát most már ideje de a legtöbbször
mégis azt tapasztaljuk hogy még az
mondom unokámér még a dédunokámér tehát
hogy az élethez való ragaszkodás úgy
gondolom hogy ez egy természetes emberi
érzés és ezt úgy ez a normális hogy
szeretünk élni
h és akkor ez a fajta tragikus eset
amikor valakinél egy
rosszindulatú esetet vélsz felfedezni ez
ez mennyire gyakori tehát hogy hetente
havonta igen azért hetente hetente és
akkor ilyenkor személyesen te mondod el
igen igen teh igazából nincs ki elmondja
nincs és ez ez az orvosbeteg
kapcsolatban úgy gondolom hogy ez a ez
az alap tehát hogy én kell közüljem a
beteggel tehát hetente előfordul hogy
ennyire súlyos kérdésekben kell beszélni
emberekkel ez mennyire terel meg
érzelmileg eléggé
az elején talán még jobban
a pályafutásom elején akkor amikor
elveszítettünk egy-egy beteget még csak
nem is mondhattam hogy az én beteg igen
mert csak rezidensként voltam jelen
akkor a a
betegápolásba akkor úgy napokig akár
gyászoltam
és akkor úgy volt egy komolyabb
beszélgetésünk a férjemmel hogy akkor
ezt így nem lehet csinálni és döntsem el
a hogyan továbbot mert hogy az ezzel
számolni kell hogy a kórházban a betegek
meghalhatnak és hogy hogy nem lehet
mindenkit hetekig gyászolni jó dehát ezt
meg tudja választani az ember
intellektuál én most nem akarom
gyászolni és nem fogod igen bizonyos
értelemben meg tudom választani azt hogy
érzelmileg mennyire kötődök egy-egy
beteghez valamennyire tehát hogy nem
tudjuk természetesen az egészzet kizárni
vagy egészen kizárni de tudatosan
hogy mennyi információt akarok a
betegről a környezetéről a családjáról
azt hogy valamelyest tudom
befolyásolni és akkor tudok objek
maradni szakmailag ha a a betegre és az
ő problémájára tudok koncentrálni és nem
arra hogy neki még otthon van három
gyereke aki ha ő most meghal árván marad
tehát hogy
igen azt látom hogy most is meg meg
megérint és egy-egy ilyenkor eszetbe jut
egy-egy konkrét eset igen igen tehát
hogy
nem nem tudunk
elhatárolódni egészen és nem is kell úgy
gondolom hogy nem is kell tehát hogy nem
gépezeteket kezelünk hanem és te se egy
gép vagy igen nem egy c gpt nem
valószínű nem is leszek pedig jó lenne
információ
szempontjából ez ez érdekes
mert számomra nagyon érdekes az hogy az
ember képes arra hogy az élet
tragédiájával szembenézzen
hogy hogy képesek vagyunk a legnehezebb
pillanatban is felállni van aki
összeomlik van aki viszont feláll és nem
tudom megmondani mi a különbség a kettő
között ugyanaz az ember nem lehet így
kívülről kiszámolni hogy hogy ha ebben a
kontextusban van akkor biztos ezt fogja
csinálni szörnyű helyzetekben szörnyű
kontextusban emberek csodálatos módon
képesek voltak felállni és a legvégsőkig
harcolni
ezek ez számomra is egy követendő
csodálatos példa amire nem hiszem hogy
képes vagyok és ugyanakkor sokkal jobb
helyzetben levő embereket ismertem én
személyesen akik akik összeroppantak a a
sokkal kisebb súly alatt és ezek egyéni
életutak egyéni
egyéni hősöket termel magából ki biztos
vagyok benne hogy te is így a a praxisod
során találkoztál pár olyan emberrel
akik hihetetlenül inspiráló módon néztek
szembe ezekkel a ezekkel a a a tragikus
hírekkel
igen végülis igen bár nem nem tudom nem
tudom hogy van-e olyan jó példa aki
emberként
nem tud megrendíteni egy tragédia tehát
hogy valami baj van akkor annak az
embernek az érzelmi világával ha nem tud
téged megérinteni egy másik embernek a
problémája én arról beszélek hogy a
saját problémát tehát hogy abban a
pillanatban amelyt meg tudod hogy
mármint megtudom én tegyük fel hogy van
egy halálos diagnózisom hogy hogyan
állok szembe ezzel a a hírrel el tudom
képzelni hog van aki pánikba esik és és
van aki van aki elgondolkozik és azt
mondja hogy eljött a pillanat és ez az
életnek a természetes része úgyhogy
felkészülök arra hogy a lehetőle
méltóságteljesebben hagyja mit a a földi
létet nem tudom hogy ezekkel
találkozol-e ennyire közelről aki igen
és azt tapasztalom hogy a kezd kihalni
ai kultúránkból azt hogy
emberséggel tisztelettel otthon
szembenézni a
halállal hanem valamiért menekülünk
ennek a gondolatától nagyon sokszor azt
tapasztalom hogy bár
a beteg tudja a család tudja hogy hogy
meg fog halni mégsem akarja ezt otthon
végigcsinálni együtt a család körében
hanem inkább beviszi a kórházba az
utolsó pillanataira
meghalni valami oknál fogva menekülünk a
ettől a történéstől az ismeretlentől nem
nem tudom mitől menekülünk egészen
pontosan megfogalmazni annyi biztos hogy
az a természetes módja hogy korábban
tapasztaltuk nagyszüleinknél hogy
elgondozták az ő nagyszüleiket vagy
szüleiket ez most már úgy kezd kikopni a
mi
társadalmunkból szeretnénk levenni ennek
a gondját ennek a lelki terhét vagy a
fizikai terhét és akár nem tudom
pontosan megfogalmazni hogy mit
szeretnénk mitől szeretnénk
megszabadulni amikor ez nagyon érdekes
amit mondasz hog ezek önként önként
döntenek úgy hogy inkább korházban
fognak igen igen igen vagy ped vagy vagy
akár családi nyomásra hogy behozzák vagy
hogy nem tudom miért nyilván hogy az is
egy egy szempont lehet hogy otthon nézni
tehetetlenül hogy szenved a
hozzátartozóm ez
eszméletlen és és nem tudok rajta
segíteni csak várjuk együtt a halált
tehát úgy gondolom hogy ennek a lelki
terhe ez ez óriási egy családra főleg
akkor hogyha ez egy gondoljunk bele egy
kétszobás tömbházlakásban ahol még még
le lehet hogy gyerekek is vannak tehát
hogy gyakorlatilag az egész család
szenved ilyen értelemben úgy gondolom
hogy egy racionális lépés hogy a a hogy
ez a kórházba tudjon
megtörténni tehát am tehát ezelőtt 150
évvel amikor igen valaki a a halálos
ágján volt akkor akkor egy udvar volt
egy lakásav kiett tényleg így
belegondolva hogy lehet hogy ott is két
szoba volt de volt egy nagyobb élettér
ahol lehetett létezni még igen igen
azért tényleg összezárva l
ezek komoly etikai kérdéseket vetnek fel
tehát hogy szinte meg is érkeztünk ahhoz
a kérdéshez ami ami amiért hívtalak ami
ami nagyon érdekel
személyesen hogy egyrészt hog hogyan tud
valaki szembenézni az élet tragédiájával
de a másik az hogy gyakorlatilag te
hetente egy
olyan környezetben vagy ahol mélységesen
valamilyen
etikai keretrendszer alapján kell tudj
hozni döntéseket tehát hogy annyira
közel kerül már ezekhez a döntésekhez
ezekhez a a kérdésekhez hogy téged is
foglalkoztat téged is mélyen valahol
megdolgoz ez a
a ez ez a
kérdéssor szóval hogy konkrétan ami
engem érdekelne az hogy hogy
találkoztál-e olyan etikai kérdéssel ami
úgy amit úgy fel is tudsz idézni ami úgy
elgondolkoztat még most is téged hogy mi
volt a helyes mi a helyes és nyilván
tanácsot adsz a családnak tanács
tanácsokat adsz a a betegnek és ezek
ezek komoly felelősségű tehát komoly
felelősséget rónnak rád
úgy gondolom hogy
mindenképpen az a tiszteséges ha ha
közölve vannak az információk a beteggel
is és a hozzátartozókkal is nagyon
sokszor szembesülök azzal hogy a
hozzátartozó megpróbálja eltitkolni a
beteg elől vagy szeretnié eltitkolni a
beteg elől a súlyos diagnózist tehát még
nem is tudjuk miről van szó de már azzal
érkezik ha kiderülne hogy nagy a baj
megkérem hogy ne szóljon neki ne mondja
el neki nem szeretném ha tudna róla ez
nyilván
hogy jogtalan tehát alapjaiban jogtalan
mert fordítva lehet a beteg kérheti hogy
én a hozzátartozóval ne közöljem hogy
neki milyen problémája van de fordítva
ennek nincs semmiféle jogi
alapja viszont az is tény hogy a
hozzátartozó az aki esetleg jobban
ismeri annak a az édesanyának vagy
apának a lelki állapotát és nyilván hogy
tudja hogy egy rossz hír mennyire fogja
őt
esetleg megviselni és pont emiatt akár a
az egészségi állapotára nézve is
negatívabb kimenetele lesz annak ha egy
információt bizonyos módon közölnek vele
mindenki amúgy te ezzel egyetértesz én
én személy szerint én én azt gondolom
hogy az ember felnőtt és felelősséget
kell tudjon vállalni önmagáért és én nem
tudom kiszámítani helyette hogy ő hogyan
fog reagálni hogyan fog reagálni így van
tehát pont emiatt ezt ezt én
mindenképpen közölni szoktam a beteggel
valamilyen formában nyilván hogy soha
nem szabad elvenni a betegtől a reményt
és akkor hogy hogy képzeljem el hy
megtiltják neked vagy bejön a a az
anyuka vagy a a pont hogy a gyerm nem
tilthatják meg mert a beteg orvos beteg
kapcsolattal el kell mondani tehát hogy
ön még akkor is hogyha egy súlyos
betegségről van szó egy leukémiáról
akkor is el kell mondani hogy indulatú
hematológiai betegség van van rá kezelés
nincs rá garancia hogy fog hatni ez a
kezelés előfordulhat hogy előre fog
haladni a probléma akár ebbe bele is
lehet halni viszont meg is lehet akár
gyógyulni mert hogy nem én vagyok az aki
ki fogom számítani azt hogy neki működni
fog a másiknak nem fog beszélhetünk
statisztikákról és azt is láthatjuk hogy
hányszor áthúzta az élet a statisztikai
adatokat mertogy teljesen más másként
működött ugyanazon diagnózisnál ugyanaz
a kezelés egyiknél évek óta működik a
másiknál nem működött egyik hónapról a
másikra nem így működik az élet hogy
vagy vagy azokra a kérdésekre amikor
jönnek hogy mennyi van még hátra nem
tudom pedig látom hogy rosszul van
statisztikai adatot tudnál mondani vagy
azt tudnám mondani hogy emberileg nézve
néhány nap alatt akár belehallhat de azt
is tapasztaltam hogy már nagyon sokszor
megfordult ez a történet és az a nagyon
rosszul levő beteg aki három napig
szinte kómában volt az hazament és
visszajár kontrollba tehát hogy nem
tudom megmondani hogy mennyi van még
ezek a legjobb tévedéseid akkor ezek
ezek komoly komoly etikai kérdések
tényleg ez ez ez felmér például nem
mondunk le a betegről alapelv tehát soha
nem mondunk le a
betegről nem nem rajtam áll hogy él vagy
hal amúgy ez az az orvosi körökben ez
egy általános nézet hogy hogy ezeket
tehát ez ez egy személyes döntésed neked
hogy elmondod és szembesíted a bet ez
egy személyes döntésem de igazából ennek
van egyedül jogi alapja is hogy hogy a
betegnek tudnia kell hogy mi a
problémája azt nem tudom hogy hát de
azér ismer pár orvost tehát hogy
körülötted nyilván hogy közölni kell a
beteggel azt hogy hogy mi a
probléma viszont az is tény hogy nem
mindig fogja fel tehát hogy én nagyon
sokszor tapasztalom azt hogy évek múlva
is úgy jön vissza a beteg hogy akkor
engem mivel is tetszik kezelni tehát
hogy vannak olyan szituációk amikor
mondunk mondunk de úgy tűnik hogy
teljesen fölösleges tehát hogy
ez már nem a te dolgod viszont nem tehát
hogy úgy úgy érzem hogy ha én közöltem
elmondtam nyilván hogy azért az mégis
csak az én felelősségem hogy meg kellene
ezt valahogy értetni a beteggel
mertogy az amit én közlök nem biztos
hogy ugyanaz a a amit ő megért belőle
tehát hogy az lenne a az ideális ha
visszakérdezek hogy mit értett meg
belőle mit hogy hogy neki mi a
problémája és nem biztos hogy ugyanaz
lenne a válasz amit én közöltem ehhez
viszont sokkal több időre lenne szükség
igen megg itt valójában az is van hogy
valamennyire azért be kell lássa az
életébe a kontextusába hogy hol él kik
veszik körbe mi fog rávárni tehát hogy
valójában a fejedben te el kell tudd
dönteni hogy érdemes-e ebbe még több
energiát ölni hogy hogy hogy az a
személy még megértse mert lehet hogy a
kontextusából ki kifolyólag szükség van
arra hogy hogy realizálja hogy mi fog rá
várni mert praktikus döntéseket kell
hozzon a következő héten és vannak
amikor egyszerűen lehet hagyni nem hogy
hogy jól van akkor most annyira nem
értette meg nem baj mert az a kontextus
amibe körbeveszi az megtartja egyrészt
másrészt viszont úgy gondolom hogy
alapvető a a az orvosbeteg kapcsolat
közti bizalom tehát hogy annak ellenére
hogy ő nem tudja hogy én mivel kezelem
visszajár a kezelésre tehát három
hetente
nyolc 28 naponta vagy havonta kontrollba
tehát hogy azt jelenti hogy van egyfajta
bizalom ami miatt oké hogy én nem értem
hogy mi az igazi probléma vagy mivel is
kezelnek engem de úgy tűnik hogy hogy ó
működik a kezelés akkor ezt kell
csinálni most hirtelen felmerül bennem
mint samel weiss ignácnak a
a az esete is hogy az orvosi társadalom
akkor amikor változott az orvostudomány
és rájöttek arra hogy valamit rosszul
tettek addig egyszerűen negatívan
reagált mert nem akartak szembenézni
azzal hogy esetleg ők voltak azok akik
rosszat tettek a az eskűük ellenére a
beteggel viszont annyira változik maga
az orvostudomány a hematológia is hogy
van-e erre példád amikor valamilyen
diagnózist felállítottál és valamilyen
kezelést beállítottál és utána tegyük
fel pár évvel később kiderült hogy az
pont hogy rosszat tett a
betegnek nincs mármint hogy nem nem így
látom a dolgot olyan szempontból hogy én
jelen pillanatban a legjobb tudásom
szerint a
jelenleg rendelkezésemre álló
információkkal együtt a beteg számára az
optimális döntést kell meghozzam és nem
tudom mi lesz a következő öt évben de az
a következő öt év története tehát hogy
nem nem gondolkodhatok úgy hogy mi lenne
ha esetleg egy pár hónap múlva ennek az
akut leukémiásnak kitalálnának egy olyan
kezelést ami 100% működne mert nem tudom
hogy mi lesz három hónap múlva de ha
most nem kezelem a jelenlegi tudásom
szerint akkor elég nagy esélye van rá
hogy az elkövetkezendő három hónapot nem
éli meg tehát hogy én úgy gondolom hogy
az a
le etikusabb az é szempontomból hogyha a
jelenleg
rendelkezésemre álló információval ami
és eszközzel ami a a kezünkben van a
legjobbathhoz döntést hozzuk meg a beteg
számára és hogyha utólag ez kiderül hogy
más kellett mást lehetett volna tenni
akkor akkor se gondolom hogy tévedtünk
akkor abban a helyzetben merthogy
mi alapján mondom hogy tévedtem 10 éve
amikor kemoterápiát állítottunk be az
krónikus limfás leukémiásnak és azzal az
élete meghosszabbodott nem volt más
lehetőség akkor azzal diagnosztizáltunk
az volt a kezelés
gyakorlatilag és élt vele a beteg éveken
vagy évtizedeket most hogy van jobb
lehetőség akkor a jobbat használjuk
nyilván hogy nem azt fogjuk
használni nem hiszem hogy ezzel a az
önmarcangoló leg ismeretfurdalásos
módszerrel kellene hozzáállni egy-egy
esethez azt hiszem hogy ennek a titka
tényleg az éberség hogy az aktuális
helyzetben a legjobb tudásod szerint
éberen figyelve tiszta lelki ismerettel
ha hozol egy döntést akkor később
ráállhatsz akár hogyha helytelen döntés
is volt tehát hogy utána nyugodtan tudsz
aludni mert az az az igazság hogy ha
valaki felelősséget vállal akkor
tévedhet és csak azt téved aki igazán
felelősséget vállal viszont nem ez nem
igaz sok sok más tévedés is
y
váakelős viszont az viszont ha nem
vagyunk éberek nem nem tiszta a
lelkiismeretünk nem a legjobb tudásunk
szerint hozzuk a a a döntéseket hanem
tegyük fel sietünk vagy unjuk vagy
vagy nem figyelünk oda megfelelően akkor
utólag szét tud tépni minket a
lelkiismeretünk hogyha ha úgy hozunk
döntéseket hogy slamposan oda nem
odafigyelve türelmetlenül és lehet hogy
ez a titkod nek hogy nyugodtan tudsz
aludni nem tudom hogy mi a titkarnak
hogy nyugodtan tudok aludni nem tudom
isten álmában is ad eleget az övéinek
nagyjából ennyi a titka mertogy nem
tudom azt mondani hogy minden egyes
beteggel tudok tölteni megfelelő időt
szeretnék tehát hogy nem ez a kérdés
hogy nem szeretném ezt jobban csinálni
de az tény hogy olyan körülmények között
hogyha egy 8olc órás munkaidőben három
helyen háromféle
helyen látom el a feladatot egy azon
időben akkor nyilván hogy ez a minőség
rovására megy tehát hogy
igyekszem a megfelelő információkat a
betegekkel közölni de nem biztos hogy
jut arra idő hogy őt is meghallgassam
esetleg minden alkalommal és ilyenkor
bizzony gondolom hogy információk az ő
szempontjából elcsúszhatnak
ezért kell újra s újra gondolni időnként
egy-egy esettel és lehet hogy ez a
szerencsém is hogy krónikus betegről van
szó aki vissza fog jönni három hét múlva
is vagy négy hét múlva is és még újra
szóba állunk és esetleg pótolhatjuk azt
ami korábban mulasztás volt vagy újra
gondolhatjuk és nem vagyok minden tudás
birtokában tehát hogy amikor bizonytalan
vagyok akkor kérdezzek meg mást kollégát
kérjek másod véleményt mutassam meg az
esetet nézze egy kívülálló szem aki
eddig még nem látta hát hogyha másként
látja tehát úgy gondolom hogy erre is
nyitottnak kell lenni a kommunikációra
vagy arra hogy tudni azt hogy tévedhetek
igen ez hogy tévedhetsz ez ez egy nagyon
érdekes kérdés mert azt hiszem hogy pont
ezt csináljuk az orvosokkal senki sem
akar egy bizonytalan orvossal találkozni
senki sem akarja azt hallani hogy egy
orvos azt mondja hogy juci néni nekem
fogalmam sincs hogy milyen vag ilyet még
soha életemben nem láttam tehát ilyet
nem akar hallani hanem ju néni egy egy
magabiztos személyt akar látni aki
szakmájának a csúcsán van és tudja
mindenre a választ egy félistent
kreálunk az orvosokból és ez egy
hatalmas teher lehet de jucci néni akkor
ahhoz fog járni kezelésre tehát nincs
ezzel semmi gond tehát úgy gondolom hogy
alapvető az orvosbeteg kapcsolat és
hogyha az illető beteg abba az orvosba
bízik meg akkor minden gond nélkül hozzá
kell járni tehát nem nem
kell nem nem gondolom azt hogy hogy ezt
felül kellene írni egy állképel
önmagamról biztos hogy azért nyomás van
rajtad hogy tudjál elvárják tőled hogy
tudjál mindent el de fogom közölni
amikor nem tudok mert hogy ez van it
tehát illetve mir miről áll miből áll a
szakmám nagyon sokszor
leveszünk egy csomó mintát vagy
elküldjük a beteget egy csomó
vizsgálatra azokat mindenki más csinálja
meg elvégzi a labororvus a szövettanász
a radiológus az imagisztikus
a sebész tehát nagyon sok más
szakterület is beleszól abba hogy amikor
ezek az információk összegyűlnek és én
értékelni fogom milyen eredményhez
jutunk ha a labororvos rosszul végezte
el a feladatát és rossz eredményt adott
akkor én rossz eredményt fogok értékelni
ha a szövettanáz elszúrta a szövettant
akkor én az a szövettan alapján fogom a
betegnek beállítani a kezelését ha a
radiológus másként értékelte az akkor
akkor nyilván
hogy olyan nincs hogy téved tetetlen
tehát hogy ez ez egy illúzió hogy hogy
nem tévedhetünk mert hogy emberi faktor
benne van és ezért gondolom azt hogy
hogy igen újra kell értékelni időnként a
dolgokat és nem baj az ha kiderül hogy
tévedtünk de úgy gondolom hogy ezzel is
korrektül kell viszonyulni ez volt a
szövettan újranéztük nem ez az eredmény
más a diagnózis akkor ezt is ugyanolyan
korrektül kell a közölni a beteggel hogy
hiba volt és ezt valahol fel kell
vállalni hogy hogy igen nem minden
tökéletes igen és gondolom hogy ebbe
segít egy egy orvosi közösség aki
körbeveszéged ugye ahogy mondtad hogy
egyrészt ez egy csapatmunka hogy egy
diagnózist felállíts de más
hematológusokkal meg más tágabb orvosi
csapattal konzultálva beszélgetve egy
egy egy közösségben azért mégis csak
könnyebb ilyen szempontból döntéseket
hozni meg elvinni az érzelmi terhét is
hogyha valamit ami számodra nem
bizonytalan vagy nem kell egyedül
felvállalod a felelősséget hát a a
felelősség azzal a beteggel kapcsolatban
akit én kezelek az nyilván engem terhel
az hogy én tanácsot kérek sok más
mindenkitől az engem segíthet de
önmagában nem rázhatom le magamról a az
egyéni felelősséget
igen a közösség a hematológiában is
tehát úgy kevesen vagyunk ezért úgy
tartjuk egymással a kapcsolatot
telefonon
merthogy azért mindegyikünk ennek
következtében eléggé leterhelt is tehát
hogy konzultálunk egymásral egy-egy eset
margójáról és ezt jó látni hogy a másik
másként látja-e esetleg vagy más
nézőpont szerint ítéli meg a feladatot
vagy jó azt is visszahallani igen úgy én
is így gondolom tehát hogy jó ez a
visszajelzés konferenciákat szerveznek
itt romániába hematológiába igen igen
romániában is többet is tehát hogy
regionálisan is helyileg is vannak
workshopok vagy az országos hematológiai
konferencia van de igyekszünk azért
máshova is elmenni és megnézni hogy
máshol hogy hogy csinálják a dolgokat
lehet szó akár az európai
kongresszusokról is vagy a külföldön
szervezett workshopokról szükséges az
hogy hú egy kicsit más társadalomban más
infrastruktúrával más lehetőségekkel más
perspektívák nyílnak és úgy gondolom
hogy nem szabad leszűkülni erre tudsz
időt szakítani muszáj tehát hogy ahhoz
hogy minőségi betegellátás legyen muszáj
kiszállni a komfortzónánkból és elmenni
tanulni nem hetente de egy évben
egyszer-kétszer
muszáj lassan a beszélgetésünk végéhez
értünk talán egy utolsó kérdésem az
lenne hogyha végtelen erőforrással
rendelkeznél mit változtatnál most a
székelyudvarhelyi kórházba mit mit mi mi
az amit a helyire tennél legszívesebben
a hematológiát
igen és a te területeden belül mi milyen
terveid lennének hogyha végtelen
erőforrást reméljük hogy a
kórházigazgató úr nézi a az adást és és
kérdezzük meg hogy akkor mit tudnánk
ilyen szempontból segíteni neked nagyon
nagyon-nagyon fontos lenne az hogy
izoláltabb helyen legyen
sokkal kisebb ágyszámú kortermek
legyenek egy két ágy kortermek amiben
most négy ágyasak öt öt ágyas két öt
ágyas korterem
illetve nagyon fontos lenne az hogy a
stabil középkáder
egy csapat alakuljon ki aki nagyon tudja
a feladatát és tisztában van azzal hogy
minek mi a
következménye és
úgy gondolom hogy hogy nem nem feltétlen
kivitelezhetetlen tehát itt nem óriási
összegekről van szó még akkor ha jól
értem azt hogy egy csapat ahhoz hogy egy
csapat ki tudjon alakulni szervezés
kérdése nagyon sok szervezés kérdése és
ezalatt azt érted hogy most ebben a
pillanatban nincsenek stabil emberek
akik folyamatosan ott lennének
körülötted és el tudnátok mé mélyülni a
a szakmába igen igen igen egyedül vagy
ilyen szempontból most igen
hematológusként egyedül
te vagy az egyetlen stabil személy akkor
egyetlen stabil személy illetve még van
egy stabil személy a járóbetegrendelőben
a nővér aki
nagyon sokat segít it ennek a
megszervezésében sok szempontból még még
hány személyre lenne szükséged akik
stabilan ott vannak hogy nyolc minimum
minimum nyolc személyre lenne szükséged
és még egy hematológus r el tudy menni
szabadságra igen igen az jól jönne jól
jönne de nagyon fontos lenne a kis ágy
kis ágyszámú kortermek kialakítása
merthogy ez gyakorlatilag egy
immundeprimált beteg kategória gyenge
immunitással akinek
egymásra is veszélyt jelentenek
önmagukra is veszélyt it jelentenek
sokszor a saját baktériumjaik
is beteggé tudják tenni tehát hogy
nagyon fontos lenne hogy ne öt ember
együtt legyen egy kóteremben hanem ennél
kevesebb szám
h köszönöm szépen hogy eljöttél számomra
nagyon izgalmas volt ez a beszélgetés
újra köszönöm és
nem is tudom hogy mit kívánjak neked
bizonyos szempontból a szakmád egy
negatív szakma nem oly mint egy építészé
aki ha valamit felépít akkor azt látja
hogy ez egy funkcionális megfogható és
pozitív kimenetelű hanem inkább olyan
mint egy teszteri szakma hogyha most a
programozási területre tévedek hogy hogy
a teszterk mindig a negatív példákat
hogyha valami nem működik azt látják és
egyflytában a hiánnyal a a a nem
megfelelő funkcionálitással találkoznak
és ezt ezt nehéz amúgy a
teszterknek
megfelelően
megélni én ebbe sok áldás kitartást
kívánok neked köszönöm szépen de azért
pozitív tehát hogyha amikor meggyógyul a
hocskinos fiatalnő és lesz két gyereke
utána akkor azt mondom hogy ő helyre
állt és a jól van azt hiszem szóval úgy
gondolom hogy ez ennél jobb mondattal
zárni nem is lehetne köszönöm szépen
aranka hogy itt voltál szivesen ha
tetszett ez a műsor akkor iratkozz fel
kérlek a csatornánkra ezzel tudsz
támogatni minket köszönjük a vckker
kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre